all right I saw the force awakens this
morning and I want to talk about it
this is completely unrestrained we've
seen the movie we're going to discuss it
I'm going to slot in some general
impressions but then the main thing I
want to talk about is kylo Ren as a
compelling villain this has been a
really good year for me in movies
there's been multiple movies this year
that I've come out of and within hours
being itching to see again fury road
Jupiter ascending and now the force
awakens I don't normally get one of
those on any given year and this year I
got three so that's the foundation we're
working from here all right
first off I think the addition of
Lawrence Caston as co-writer and
Kathleen Kennedy's producer has brought
out to jab Rome's best work I enjoy the
JJ Abrams style even as I poke fun at it
but the way it's tempered and restrained
here is fantastic JJ Abrams has always
excelled at creating moments but tends
to lose interest with the connecting
tissue Caston script helps keep things
cohesive the visual language is also
significantly more restrained with far
more judicious use of the JJ Abrams
style given that he's working with his
normal DP and editing team of dan
Mendell Marion Brandon and Mary Jo
Markey I would almost certainly
attribute this to Kennedy's guiding hand
as it shows the measured deliberateness
of the Spielberg films Kennedy has
worked on but now let's talk about the
script the one real problem is that it's
perhaps a little too aware that it's a
highly anticipated Star Wars film there
are so many secrets that it's easy to
lose track of exactly whose mysterious
backstory we know and whose we don't
know and when there's that many balls in
the air it can undermine some of the
reveals in particular Ray's parentage is
withheld from the audience through to
the end of the film but the way Han and
Maz talk about her made me think that
I'd missed something
I felt like Han and Maz know who her
parents are but just didn't bother to
tell the audience especially since ray
and kylo Ren have the same mystery from
the audience's perspective namely who's
your daddy at times it feels like it's
just hitting the same note over and over
again speaking of reveals the single
most effective reveal in the film is
basically an anti reveal when Rey and
kylo Ren have their standoff during
Rey's interrogation he takes off his
helmet to reveal absolutely nothing
there's nothing wrong with him his mask
is a mask in the purest sense it
is a persona that he has adopted in an
attempt at making himself more like his
idol Darth Vader and really this brings
us to the core I could just get out
forever about kylo Ren this is a
fantastically well realized villain with
minimal exposition at a few small
montages we learned so much about what
drives him I mean this is just a great
example of showing instead of telling no
one ever has to say out loud
Oh kylo Ren he's just impulsive jealous
insecure and prone to fits of vengeful
rage we see it he overreacts to setbacks
with lashing violence he gets caught up
in petty challenges to his pride he
lunges at Finn screaming traitor because
Finn's defection embarrassed him in
front of supreme leader and general Hux
he tries to wear the legacy of his
grandfather assuming the mannerisms of
power and control but it's ultimately
all an act with mere fragmentary
flashbacks we understand his backstory
intuitively that his insecurity and
sense of inadequacy would foster
resentment and jealousy leading to him
lashing out with violence the way that
he venerates his grandfather's legacy
and tries so hard to remake himself in
Vader's image while falling short he
lacks Vader self control and confidence
he wants to be the right hand of power
but he's reckless and insecure and that
tragically makes him into a blunt
instrument for smarter more conniving
forces this is a wonderfully compelling
villain and I would have never guessed
I'd be saying that about a character
whose summary is literal darth vader
wannabe it's great and it's compelling
because it's not just diegetic lee
believable but because we can see
ourselves reflected back in him we can
relate to feeling small and helpless and
ignored and wanting to prove everyone
wrong kylo Ren Ben solo is an extension
of us and our fears
he is our universal pain brought to the
point of obsession extended to the realm
of tragedy he lives in the shadow of a
man he is mythologized a grandfather he
never met and resents the flawed and
human father he has he is us and that's
scary it's great also it's great that
he's not named Darth a bad guy